[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for taking
time out of your busy next schedule to
join us today my name is Megan O'Keefe
I'm a developer advocate here at Google
Cloud I'm so thrilled today to be joined
by four wonderful panelists to chat all
things platform engineering raise your
hand if this is a topic that is a out of
exciting to you or you're you're here to
okay good you're in the right room that
was mostly that that was what I was
checking awesome so um yeah with the pl
panelists go ahead and like to introduce
themselves Evan wood uh director of
cloud engineering at Home
Depot I'm Tim Hansen engineer on the
backstage team at
Spotify I'm denish um I'm the staff
engineer Tech lead of the platform
infrastructure from merari I'm David
Faircloth director of platform
engineering at the Wendy's company
awesome great so thrilled to have all of
you here today I guess I kind of want to
start with a very broad general question
I think we hear a lot about devops
platform engineering these terms that
are that mean different things to
different people I'm curious for each of
you in your organization what does
platform engineering mean right
now so we've been doing platforms of
some form at Home Depot web spere a
while ago PCF for a while um so I think
the big shift for us is actually
developing our own platforms versus
managing and running the platforms um as
we've done in the
past yeah platform has been around a
long time at Spotify started years and
years ago we had tons of production
incidents one week and we were like
someone needs to watch after the
infrastructure basically and that was
years ago now and now we have a huge
platform organization um so really it's
an accelerent for us for the rest of our
teams yep for merari platform
engineering is um uh providing secure
reliable and scalable infrastructure to
our developers and so that they can
basically deploy and uh build and deploy
their applications on the platform y
platform engineering is actually a
pretty New Concept for us here at
Wendy's um we've through the years and
doing Cloud things uh you have bits and
parts of systems that are owned by
different people and different teams so
you have the security and networking and
all the different teams have a little
bit of piece of the pie and what we
realize with that is when that happens
nobody really owns anything so we took
this extreme ownership approach with PL
platform engineering where we have a
team that owns the whole stack except
soup nuts so if it's a networking
problem it's one team's doing that or
security or whatever it is um with that
we've been able to usher in that devops
culture of Partners ship and what that
means across the stack so um for us it
really means that extreme ownership uh
and really the implementation of that
devops culture of collaboration and
communication thanks all kind of moving
more into the sort of uh how and and
what I'm curious organizationally how
your platform team is is structured um
maybe team size um the kinds of skills
you look for in your platform team and
kind of you know the domain of
expertise I have to first say that there
are many platform teams at Home Depo so
uh talking about kind of uh application
platforms um my team which also handles
most of cloud uh from a kind of
governance uh security perspective um
we're about 50 people uh about 15 of
those software engineers and then a mix
of uh systems engineering skills to
support the underlying
infrastructure
yeah at Spotify we have a pretty big
team for our platform organization it's
actually a whole organization um but
they look after not only infrastructure
but also developer Effectiveness and
developer
experience um and we've found the need
to create even more platforms as we've
gone along so we have a Commerce
platform that handles payments
throughout
Spotify um but our real goal is just to
make de Vel opers faster you know
whatever that means whether it's
managing the infrastructure for them or
providing the tools that they need to do
their job more
efficiently yep uh same for marari as
well so um we have a platform division
which is divided into four different
teams so platform uh DX which is the
developer experience who looks after the
developer productivity and experience uh
of our platform basically uh then we
have a um cicd team who looks after the
cicd uh requirements for our users then
we have um platform Network team and
platform infrastructure team so both of
them looks after the their dedicated
space so Network space is handled by
Network team and Cloud infra is handled
by platform infra team which is my team
uh we also have observability uh
responsibility as well so the
observability for uh the applications
which are deployed on the platform as
well as observability for the platform
itself and on top of that observability
for the observability as
well uh we take a lot of the same
approaches that Tim was talking about um
developer productivity uh time to market
for applications and those types of
things but we also from a team siiz
perspective uh do a two two pizza box
team um we're we're pretty big fans of
teams of six to eight people that can be
fed by two pizza boxes that they can
remain small and Nimble to do what you
want to to and Achieve what you want
them to without the whole analysis
paralysis aspect to it you get too many
smart rooms uh smart people into a room
and you kind of get analysis paralysis
going on and we try to stay away from
that by keeping our team small and
Nimble gotcha thank you sort of going
off of that what I'm curious about is
kind of the interactions between teams
so you mentioned some of you have
multiple platform teams that have to
work together and then of course there's
the interface between the platform teams
and their stakeholders all of the
application developers and analysts and
all the people that they're serving can
you talk a bit about how that works
within your or um and maybe some
challenges you've
had sure that's where most of my time is
spent so I yeah I think that you first
and foremost and I think people can
relate is getting cyber on board early
um in partnering heavily with their
cyber team um and they're huge
supporters at this point they look to
the things we make sure that the latest
cyber goodness is baked into the
platform and then they're comfortable
pointing uh uh teams to the platform to
use because of that so um then it's
relationships with all of the
development directors uh that are out
there and there's they all have
different needs and and wants um and so
really it's a it's we're constantly
working with the both the developer
community and the cyber community to
make sure and the SRE Community uh to
make sure that everything's baked in uh
uh to meet the
needs yeah as far as teams working
together at Spotify um we we structured
teams under product areas so if you have
a bunch of teams that are looking at the
same sort of thing you know they're
expected to work together and you can
structure that in your org and there's
this whole question of like should your
org match your technology basically so
we've looked at that tried to figure out
you know how best to structure our teams
and uh how can we get them collaborating
well
together yep um yeah in marari basically
all the platform uh teams basically they
they share the release cycle and uh the
release candidates basically so that
they can create um um output for our
developers so we uh follow platform as a
uh product principles so by following
that principle we would like to deliver
uh platform offerings or platform
deliverables to our um uh users who are
the developers and working with the
development teams we basically um make
use of the user surveys interviews to uh
get to know them what are their problems
how they are dealing with uh the sdlc
life cycle uh the development life cycle
basically and um and we also have
started to have uh dedicated TPMS for
our uh platform uh group itself so
following the platform as a product
mindset
yep yeah I think back to what everyone
was saying too about collaboration and
getting cyber security on board and
everything like that it's it's really
that with all of our partners um so the
way we've implemented it with the
collaboration working with other teams
is openness um anybody's invited to our
stand-ups any day come to it find out
what we're working on give us feedbacks
we also have um weekly touch points with
all of our other stakeholder groups like
cyber security where we meet with them
or they come alongside and they'll do a
couple of Sprints with us those types of
things um but with that you also have to
worry about the unplanned work aspect to
it um that all those collaboration
points are going to have to it so we
actually run what we call patrolman so
we actually have one engineer on our
team that's dedicated for a day a week
that he is going to focus on the
unplanned work that comes in so if we
have a developer that has a question or
somebody needs access to something or
how to get started in those types of
questions they just come and hit us up
in a channel our patrolman's already
dedicated to taking that work and what
that allows the rest of the team to do
is focus on their deep work and move
their cards through so that's really how
we've decided to take that on as a group
is you know we have our state of the
platform monthly we have our stand-ups
daily that people can join but also we
have that unplanned work aspect there
that we can plan for um and make sure
that the rest of the team is dedicated
for that deep work super interesting
thanks all all right let's dive into
some of the uh n nitty-gritty here so
I'm curious for each of you and each of
your orgs what do you use to build your
platform is it handrolled do you use
open source tools do you uh you know use
a combination do you have multiple
platforms I'm very very curious
and I I think high level I think of us
at my team managing three platforms one
is the cloud management platform we
primarily use Hashi cor stack for that
um and we buy the co the using using
commercial software for a number of
years now um the managed application
platform we're building is based on gke
uh so I think a component uh familiar
but then we're using terraform to
automate everything around it in the
project
um I also say uh Google workflows uh for
an orchestrator I think in building a
platform you have to have some kind of
orchestration um we've adopted Google uh
workflows which has been awesome
code-based workflow engine um to to help
with
that yeah we use a lot of different
Technologies we use a bunch of Open
Source Technologies uh we run most of
our workloads on gke
similarly uh we have our own in-house uh
developed developer portal called
backstage which is now open source um
and we made that years and years ago
there was nothing out there at the time
that existed that served that need so
something we had to kind of invent
inhouse and it's something that we've
shared out with the open source
Community now because we love open
source you know we we want to be good
citizens um but we use tons of Open
Source tools like Jenkin flight you know
gke
Etc yep for merari we uh use of the
Shelf tools uh basically um lot of our
workload is already on uh gcp so we use
gcp comput then um kubernetes engine
then we use cloud build for our monor
repo CI um where we run terraform inside
it then we use cloud storage for for
storing our um artifacts and logs uh
then uh we use artifacts registry as
well container registry uh we are in the
migration phase of uh container registry
to artifact registry at the moment um
for deployment uh delivery basically we
use uh Spiner um then uh we also started
to use Argo CD so for that as well we
are in the middle of migration um then
uh uh we also have have uh selfhosted uh
GitHub Runners which is the custom um
build solution inside our platform group
then we have um a
um secure CI that we call it so that is
actually based upon the cloud build uh
and we run terraform inside it uh we
also have temporary access management we
um follow the zero touch production um
principle where we don't allow
by default access to our service
developers so they if they want to have
access they can basically quickly go
ahead and uh uh submit a workflow for
temporary access which will be um uh
granted immediately after approval by
the owner team and it is time bound so
it will be uh revoked after a certain
time uh yeah
that's we take the same approach um one
of our platform principles is prefer
service offerings we available and
appropriate um so we choose to there's
an open source tool out there let's go
look at that and use that at all
possible there's certain times that
that's not going to work so we'll go and
use a tool that we have to pay for um
the only time that we build stuff in
house is if it's not available out there
already yet or if it provides a
competitive Advantage for us so those
are the only two times that we'll
actually build it in house ourselves but
we typically try to prefer those open
source toolings I mean we're backstage
fans um love it it's a great Tool uh if
you haven't checked it out yet go check
it out there's a plug for Tim um but
yeah that's that's how we decide to appr
everything is is platforms are really
just a big old puzzle and you have to be
able to find the right puzzle piece
that's going to fit into it to give you
what you want and so it's creating those
integration points but it's back to
another platform principle of automation
too of you need to automate all the
things and that's really where the the
key aspects come in is go and identify
what your tools are going to be and you
spend your time automating it so your
developers don't have to worry about
those
aspects nice well uh all of yall
mentioned a bunch of interesting gcp
products and and open source tools which
is very interesting to me want to come
back to that before we do I'd love to
hear from each of you about kind of the
core features in your internal platform
so you know in a tool like backstage
right you've got Tech docs and and
self-service and software catalog what
would you say are maybe the top two or
three features in your platform and kind
of um you know at what is at the core of
of what you're building for your
deps so and to go back to
self-service um which is really the
difference between just providing in
Automation and providing experience for
our developers um to get what they need
with as little friction as possible um
we spend a lot of time uh working on
self-service we we're not using
backstage uh but I like it uh because we
started about a couple years ago uh
building our own portal um and so that
was a tough decision to do but I think
that when you look at a lot of the tools
The open- Source tools uh and Commercial
tools one of the things that's lacking
in is a great self-service option that
meets Home Depot's needs uh where we are
and so we knew we were going to have to
customize um and and so we went on that
Adventure um and it's worked out uh
pretty well so far but on self-service
product mindset I'd say is uh changing
even my own developers from thinking
about just providing a good script or a
good set of automation but to really
thinking about our developers as
customers that we have to serve and what
their needs really are and then making
the interface in a way that's good for a
developer uh and and put a lot of focus
on that so I just say for product uh
sorry for uh platform Engineering in
general is the product mindset for us
that really helps us so the technology
selections are
important but making sure that it's
knowing who your customer is and
building that self-service option is
really the the key to it for us
yeah I definitely Echo some of those
sentiments um we always treat developers
as customers in our platform
organization and we've even had you know
marketing teams uh marketing things
internally because you need to treat
Engineers as a customer especially at
Spotify when we're so
autonomous um you can't just dictate
that teams will use your platform no
matter what you know there's a lot of
freedom there but the core features I'd
say of Backstage anyway are not just a
software catalog but a software graph
that tells you how all of our software
is interconnected with each
other um and our goal is really to make
developers able to grasp and understand
the software ecosystem at Spotify so not
only the stuff that you work on but the
stuff that's in a whole other part of of
the company you should be able to go and
read documentation understand the
services um so the software graph is a
big deal as well as uh software
templates for spinning up new things we
have search integration across
everything because you need to be able
to quickly find
things um and Tech dos you mentioned is
our solution for technical
documentation that stays uh up to date a
little more naturally than riding an
often some disconnected Wiki
somewhere yep I think for us as well it
is the same so it's kind of a common
pattern to have self-service uh
templates and the interface that we
provide to our developers so for us as
well our interface is mostly uh based
upon the um terraform modules so we
created a terraform modules on top of
the terraform um uh Native resources
that we can create with terraform so
that's a interface we provide just a
small template variable file which is
exale based uh TF file to our developers
and they can just quickly set the the
variables and once they set the variable
behind the scene entire terraform code
is generated for creating or generate um
configuring the uh Cloud resources for
them so that's about the gcp part uh for
the kubernetes part uh we have uh fully
migrated to having Q language based
abstraction so we don't uh let users
write yamal anymore so Q language helps
us to do um Dynamic validation for yls
and they can easily set certain
variables and behind the scene uh the
entire kubernetes files will be
generated for them um yeah so for us the
topmost um uh that we are proud of is
the U um self-serving templates and the
interface that we provide to our uh
users
yep yeah same for us it's the the
automation aspect that you can bring to
it so when you have an application
deployed you know that in every
environment it's going to be the the
exact same bringing that item potency to
the sdlc um as part of that our core and
best product offering that we're really
proud of within our team is um the
aspect that the developers don't have to
worry about the infrastructure when they
deploy an application they give us a
manifest file that says I need public
Ingress to it I need a database I need a
cach whatever that looks like they can
give us all those details in the
Manifest file when that's put in through
the pipeline it's all automatically
created so they don't have to worry
about the user provisioning to go talk
to the database or any of that it's all
automa automatically built for them um
as part of that uh another number two I
guess for us would be around our
documentation as we talked about um
we're we're big on write it in one spot
um and then have it consumable for the
world so uh we try to track all of our
git repos where that's our source of
Truth for documentation and then we use
tools like Mark to push it up into uh
where our document store is so we can
actually have that all git based all of
our version history right there and then
we have our automation tools to actually
publish that out so people can consume
that but they don't have to worry about
going and updating it in 12 different
spots or you know oh this documentation
is now out of date because it's sitting
right next to the
code you know each of you has brought up
gke a couple of times and kind of
building platforms on top of that
extracting I'm curious if for each of
you what have been some some challenges
or I guess how do you pick the right
levels of abstraction so for example gke
has clusters name spaces pods these may
be familiar to some of us in the
audience here what do you uh expose app
developers to how do you decide and have
you have you had to kind of change your
Approach at any point with
gke I'll go ahead and take this one
first Evan because you've been going
first every time that's just not fair
um uh yeah we we constantly struggle
with that with our teams um it's talking
to your developers talking to your
clients because that's really who our
customers are so working with them on
what they want to be um what they want
to care about and do and what they don't
want to so it's really that line that
you have to constantly talk and that's
part of the colle collaboration aspect
of here's what we implementing because
that's what we think you might want so
let's work on that and see if that's
really working for you and What needs to
change with that so we're constantly
having those feedback loops with them
and changing our approach with it
depending on what's good for the
development team at the time and what
they no longer care about because what
they cared about two years ago they
don't necessarily care about it anymore
so we'll go ahead and create those
abstraction layers on top of that as
much as they want
need I'd say uh our Cloud Model uh up
until recent ly has been what I'd call
ad hoc and we have over a thousand gcp
projects um and teams can spin up their
own GK today so I could tell you our bin
packing does not look good across the
Enterprise right so I think the the
shift we're taking with platform is
moving to basically name space as a
service so the self-service is to
receive a name space we call a tenant
and then we wrap everything around uh
that that's needed for for the developer
and so one of the change hard things is
abstracting away the project view right
so we're going to have a cluster that's
going to be multi-tenant but we don't
necessarily want our developers to be
able to see everything that's in the
project so we've had to build kind of
our own context around once you own a
tenant um we then have to track all the
assets uh through tagging ass associated
with that tenant I know there's teams
inside of Google working working on uh
making a solution for that avail able
but that's one of the biggest challenges
one abstracting away from the project
which is too much information for a
developer uh in most cases um to to just
to deploy an app um and then really
focusing on the name space tenant in GK
as opposed to handing out clusters with
one app per you know per cluster in the
worst case scenario
yeah yeah I definitely Echo both of
those things we have one team at Spotify
that manages is all of our clusters
they're multi-tenant clusters and like
Dave said you know what does developer
need to know we've kind of abstracted
most of that away we don't want all of
our developers to be experts at
kubernetes that's just not a good use of
their time so we have Central teams that
manage those and make it easy for teams
to deploy to kubernetes without having
to know where the Clusters are exactly
what they want they just say I want to
be in these regions you know send it
away yep I think it is same for us as
well so we have a dedicated team uh
developer experience team who looks
after the abstraction layer of our
platform uh they
continuously uh do the user surveys and
interviews to understand what are our
users requirements um when we started
with our platform we also had the same
question like what to abstract what not
to and um uh the basic what we U did is
uh we created a basic abstract section
for our platform and um uh for rest of
the customizations or the customer
requirements that we used to get from
users uh we used to allow lowlevel um
configuration and customization to our
developers um then uh over the period uh
we started to review what are the common
um uh practices or what are the common
requirements that we have from users and
start to basically uh create abstraction
on top of that and then basically help
them to migrate to this new abstraction
so over the period we realiz we have
realized that uh platform engineering
for us is started to be migration
engineering uh so we have to like do the
migrations a lot uh while keeping U the
abstraction in our mind and basically um
um having indicators for developer
productivity and developer experience so
as much as possible how we can speed up
and accelerate uh the process for our
developers so keeping that particular uh
in mind we started to do these a survey
create obstructions do the migration so
that's how we do and I I'll add to that
it's a slippery slope um whenever you
start abstracting too much uh then
people are like well I don't have any
visibility anything how do I know what's
going on in those types of things so
when we do those types of things we try
to make sure that the way our pipelines
run what the developers can see they can
run locally on their own machine too so
there's a lot of value in creating like
your own C tool for instance that you
can actually hook all your integration
points into um that also allows quick
and easy technology exit ramps uh where
your developers can go in and grab the
CLI tool they can start running it exact
same commands and get that feedback
directly on their machine but also if
you have a new technology you're
introducing or you're changing out or
anything you do that in the CLI tool and
all the developers are getting that
immediately and they can have those
faster feedback loops and kind of dig in
a little further so it's it's definitely
that slippery slope because there's some
developers that they want it all they
want to be the masters of kubernetes
then you have others that are like whoa
I I write Java and that's all I want to
do and so it's really that talking to
your customers identifying what they
want great points I guess didn't you
bring up a really interesting point
about sort of heterogeneous
infrastructure you know in some cases it
might be all gke all the time in some
cases you know you might have a bunch of
Legacy infrastructure and bringing up
the dev keynote from earlier I guess
like in the audience here like raise
your hand if you're kind of dealing with
multiple types of infrastructure
underlying so maybe a mixture of
Greenfield Brownfield Legacy new yeah a
lot of us and the pain the pain can be
real um I'm curious for all of you you
know when it comes to dealing with
different types of infrastructure maybe
dealing with many gcp and other Cloud
products at a time what have been some
learnings that you that you've had or
maybe some some things that you did that
maybe if you went back you would you
would change in kind of your
implementation it's a kind of a loaded
question so yeah you want to take that
first sure I can go after that one um so
sptify is mostly on gcp
uh but we've acquired some companies
that use AWS so now we're in a
multicloud situation like many people um
and this the thing we've tried to do is
to uh abstract that a little bit and
we've been able to use our developer
portal to do that you know so if your
build runs on AWS or gcp it still looks
the same and if you move from one team
to another you have the same interface
that you're used to looking at now that
requires a little bit of investment in
your platform team kind of creating
these tools and these abstractions and
like Dave says there's always uh
developers who want the nuts and bolts
so you have to kind of tow that line a
little bit make it easy but still
possible to do powerful things if you
want to um yeah that's a little bit of
an
answer so we we have many many
collections of different tools Stacks uh
and so I
think the looking at the future it's how
do you build something people want to
come to and solves problems and easy to
come to right and we spend a lot of time
figuring out how can we do things for
developers there is the trade-off then
that they don't understand necessarily
what they're getting so we have to
provide a good orientation um on the
other side of it but I think it's really
about building something they can come
to and and move to as AO trying to
retrofit or fix everything that's Legacy
is not possible and there's not enough
time in the day so
yeah yeah I think abstraction or the
interface actually really plays a key
role here so if you have an abstraction
behind the scene what technology or what
vendor you use uh hardly matters
actually but of course you have to have
that much reach abstraction on top of it
and of course the vendors that you're
going to choose need to have the same
capabilities behind the scene for
example Autos scaling or automated
Resource Management so if the different
vendor you are choosing does not have
that kind of capabilities you're going
to have to basically change that
abstraction or do some hacking over
there yeah I mean hide and sight's 2020
um you're going to do things you're
going to fail with it you wish oh man I
wish we wouldn't have spent so much time
on that or something like that um the
way we approach that we have terrif
terrific leadership that they always
push the art of the possible for us
what's actually possible for us to do
and innovate and those types of things
which allows us to not be afraid to make
decisions and go down a path um as long
as we're sticking to our guiding
principles uh we were very heavy on
technology exit ramps so even though
times that we've made a decision of hey
we're going to go do this we're going to
implement it this way and it didn't turn
out how we wanted it to we're able to
exit off that technology in a pretty
seamless manner without our developers
being impacted um it's just our
engineering team from the platform side
that actually even knows about it at
that point um so I really wouldn't take
any of that away or redo any of it
because those are all learning
opportunities for every person on our
team and in the company so um I I find
Value in those failed attempts at things
just as much as the successful ones so I
wouldn't take away any of them gota
awesome I guess Evan you you bring up
something uh that I think is quite
important which is you know you can
build a portal but the developers might
not come or you can enforce it but then
you might have devs who you know go off
and and build their own how do you
measure the success of your platform
internally so do you have metrics that
that you're looking to to move what's
what's the needle you're trying to
change um have you solicit feedback I'm
really curious about that yeah in first
I'll say and you mentioned leadership we
have incredibly supportive leadership
and it hasn't always been the case it's
been an evolution getting to this point
we wouldn't be able to do what we're
doing if it was just me screaming into
the wind every day it wouldn't work so
we do have very supportive uh uh
leadership um across the board on that
um I
yeah yeah see at Spotify we have kind of
this famous culture of autonomy and we
couldn't as a platform organization
dictate like this is what you're going
to use it just wouldn't have worked so
what we had to do was to involve all the
teams you know basically to um
distribute the ownership of our
platforms and treat them as products as
Dave said you know our developers are
our customers and we need to make them
happy so it's not just a matter of like
having this Monopoly and having a
captive audience because they're forced
to use your stuff it's more like you
need to build it in a good way you need
to make sure developers are happy that
you're solving their problems so we do a
lot of um qualitative surveys so we
survey our developers quarterly ask them
about all the tools that they use to
make sure that we're meeting their
needs um and we also look at
quantitative measures you know like
pushes to production or number of
incidents things like that to make sure
that we're heading in the right
direction
yeah um at marari actually honestly we
are not doing good work around this um
uh we U measure some quantitative
metrics the famous Dora metrics
basically so like uh lead time or the
change failure rates or the de
deployment frequency availability uh SLO
metrics basically and um on the other
hand uh as uh he said uh qualitative
metrics for example satisfaction of of
our users um then we try to get that
with uh user feedback and interviews
basically but it's up to uh the
developers or uh the people you are
talking to basically you you're not
going to get the same feedback or the
honest feedback all the time so it's
really hard to basically get honest
feedbacks around that part so uh that's
just about U the qualitative uh like
user satisfaction uh but we really want
to uh solve or improve the developer
experience and productivity uh from that
perspective platform is one of the uh uh
area that we are providing where we
would be able to increase their
productivity other parts are basically
uh their cognitive load on our
developers uh and the Flow State
basically they have to do contact
switching for different kinds of things
so these are the different uh metrics
that we can use for um
uh increasing the developer productivity
but for the qualitative metrics
basically we are not doing good job but
for the quantitative T metrics uh we
have those yeah we make use of
those yeah we we use our patrolman a lot
uh for things like that that unplanned
work aspect because what that ha what
happens with that is it's no longer DMS
um to somebody or a oneoff email or
anything like that we actually get them
in our Channel all the time that are
publicly visible to everybody so we can
pull our metrics on how are we doing
from this perspective how many requests
we're getting and things like that and
where our unplanned work is coming from
um all of our developers are in our
stand-ups we're in their stand-ups those
feedback loops are as about as tight as
they can possibly be so we're getting
feedback daily from that um but from a
platform side we we and really an entire
digital development side is we look at
the DOR metrics that's something that
we've been trying to look at more this
year um if you guys haven't had a chance
go down to the booth dor metrics talk to
Nathan Harvey he's wonderful they got a
lot of great stuff that they're working
on there um and that's how we that's how
we really look at it is what is our what
is our time to release a change what
does that look like how are we speeding
up or getting better and those of things
and really grading ourselves pretty
harshly on the the quality of software
we're delivering the quality of platform
we're delivering and where our trouble
points are so so having something like
Dora metrics to be able to help create
that bench line Force has been hugely
helpful awesome thanks so much for that
all right I've got one more question
here let's look ahead to the Future a
little bit so you know platform
engineering you know take it what you
will it's a it's not like it's building
of a platform is new but we're
definitely in what feels like a bit of a
hype cycle with this topic looking ahead
in the next year in your organization
you know what are some uh some
initiatives or some some things that you
would like to improve or change about
your platform Andor where do you see the
ecosystem headed so kind of uh more
broadly and I going back to metrics
first uh we do my biggest one right now
is we've got 3,800 apps on PCF we need
to move off now whether they move to the
new
platform uh isn't a requirement but they
need to move off of it so 3,800 to zero
is is the biggest metric I work off but
we do we've got a full-time product
manager uh net promoter scores cause we
we we do surveys as well so I mean
really getting the feedback is important
the future really what we're launching
now is our future so we're very much uh
continuing the journey building a
managed application platform that
abstracts everything away is pretty
ambitious um and uh so I I think the you
know with tools like backstage and some
of the other helpers out there uh today
uh there's a lot of you know lot of
possibilities on the front end portal
side um uh but really figuring out how
to get those abstraction layers right
and uh uh making sure the developer has
a good experience um is going to be the
continued
Focus yeah it's a um we have two at
Spotify um one is called defrag like the
old windows tool you know basically
trying to reduce software fragmentation
at Spotify because we have too many
Technologies and that doesn't allow us
to build an effective platform you know
so that's one effort and at the same
time we're expanding the tools that we
use so we have ai ml you know these new
areas that we're investing in that
themselves need a platform because
they're still still new and
maturing so we've developed like a
sophisticated ml platform we're looking
at different types of platforms that we
need to expand to and we're looking at
how AI can actually help the platform
itself you know like summarizing code
reviews or um providing suggestions for
users of our portal that sort of
thing yeah I think it is pretty much
same for us as well so uh for mercari uh
we we really want our platform to be uh
uh a way to increase developers
productivity and um uh we are basically
heading over how we can increase
developers productivity and inreach or
reach uh developer experience so
platform is one of the way but um uh on
top of that we will be creating um uh
the abstractions so that they're going
to have to uh make less changes or just
set some of the variables or make use of
developer portal basically so that that
part basically we will be putting a lot
of efforts on so that we can increase
the developer
productivity and uh maybe one of the uh
ideal state that we we are looking
forward is to having a platform as a
service which is going to be the
internal uh but we are not yet sure
that's going to be the solution for us
because of course that also has Downs
sites kind of instruction we can have or
the customizations we can have so that
actually has problems platform as a
service but if you um do the uh user
surveys or understand your users really
well you can have uh the required
abstractions and have platform
accessories for your internal users so
that's where we are heading man we made
it like 37 minutes without saying AI
that's got to be a new record for these
breakout sessions we all needed a bit of
a break sorry guys
no I think I think that's a very
appropriate uh piece of where I see
platform engineering going is is what do
this this AI look like in the new world
with platforms um platform engineering
is already a new enough terminology that
not everybody's doing um and so that's
just going to put another spin on it of
of what those look like going forward
and what those teams and um structure
needs to look like if your developers
aren't uh having to write as much code
um and those types of things and really
how that's going to implement there um
for us internally really see that next
evolution is just the continuing of uh
promoting what platform engineering is
as everybody knows here when you try to
make changes like that the culture is
always the hardest part to try to change
I'm and go through so it's really just
continuing to talk about what it is and
what it's doing and setting up that
community of practice better we have a
terrific data platform team that they do
some pretty amazing stuff on that and
it's coming together with that Community
Practice and identifying how we can get
those synergies between each other and
figuring out how we can build on what
they've done and and vice versa and
everything that's really where I see um
it going internally here in
Wendy's gotcha right thank you all so so
much um right so we're running out of
time here I just want to give a huge
round of applause to our four panelists
foring thank you thank you thank
[Applause]
you and uh I just want to you know shout
out you know I think this is a nent
space there's tons of interesting
conversations to be had for sure um if
you scan this code um QR code there is a
recent blog post you know from gcp
covering some ideas around platform
engineering I would encourage you if you
haven't checked out the what's new in
cicd talk you know it's but a piece of
the platform engineering story but it's
a really great talk and um there's a
there's a repeat of that tomorrow um if
you have questions um you know we'll try
to you know hang off to the side here um
want to thank you all so much for your
time please enjoy the rest of your Cloud
next thank
[Applause]
you